monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues je souhaite que nous
saluons la mémoire du président du
parlement européen
david sassoli cesser dès hier
il personnifié par ses qualités propres
et dans l'exercice de ses
responsabilités les valeurs de l'union
européenne
c'était un homme de liberté
en tant que journaliste il connaissait
plus que tout autre le prix de la
liberté d'expression et la liberté de la
presse il était libre d'esprit
indépendant
peu enclin à suivre les mots d'ordre
dawkins et man
c'était un homme intrinsèquement attaché
au parlementarisme
il n'aura eu de cesse pendant la
pandémie de covin et nous avions échangé
d'éviter que la démocratie soit mise
entre parenthèses de rappeler sans
relâche les prérogatives du parlement en
l'occurrence le parlement au t1 id
appelé à la responsabilité de chacun
pour que l'urgence ne justifie jamais
que l'on en outre pas ce que l'on prête
avec désinvolture la représentation
parlementaire
comme président du parlement européen
issu un homme à l'écouté de l'ensemble
des sensibilités politiques représentés
y compris les plus éloignés de la sienne
en témoignent les dommages à la suite de
sa disparition en provenance de tous les
états membres de toutes les sensibilités
politiques
c'était un européen de conviction
ici la vieille europe passionnément
italien c'est à dire pétri d'une
histoire européenne il a incarné ce qui
nous unit la démocratie l'état de droit
et les droits de la personne mais aussi
cette culture en partage à la fois
si évident qu est si difficile
à définir dans lesquels les européens
avec chacun leurs spécificités
leurs identités se reconnaissent partout
chez eux au sein de l'union du nord au
sud d'est en ouest c'était un homme
courageux qui a tenu à exercer ses
responsabilités jusqu'au bout malgré la
maladie sa détermination susi a forcé
l'admiration
alors que nous entamons la présidence
française de l'union européenne dans son
volet parlementaire par la réunion à
partir de demain au sénat de la
conférence des organes spécialisés dans
les affaires communautaires la cosac
j'ai souhaité que le sénat lui rendent
hommage
je vous remercie
[Musique]